Take down competence.
That's fundamentally the underground
motivation is to blur the line between
competence and power.
And then to make anyone who manifests
any competence feel as if they're doing
nothing but manifesting tyranny.
And it's a terrible doctrine.
And I've seen it really destroyed people.
I literally,
I've seen it destroy people.
And in what context?
Well,
if you're punished every time you do
anything forthright and courageous and
noble,
buy,
buy as a consequence of accusations
of tyranny and oppression,
then everything you do
that's good is punished.
And there's Nicha pointed out,
if you really want to punish someone,
you punish them for their virtues,
not for their faults.
If you really want to hurt someone,
if I punish you because you've done
something wrong and you know you've done
something wrong,
you might not be happy punishment.
Well,
but at least it sets the scales right
and that Starsky Dostoyevsky's steam in
his great novel crime and punishment.
You know,
where,
where the murderer actually cries out to
the heavens to be punished because it's
the only way that he can
reestablish his humanity.
But if you really want to hurt people,
then you punish them for their virtues.
And we're definitely in this situation
and I think the universities have played
a major role in this were forthright
action on the part of ambitious and
productive individuals is confused
with tyrannical oppression.
And a lot of that's a consequence of
the disturbed relationships between,
well many of the people who take that
tack in the social activist domains in
universities and have never had a
healthy relationship with someone who
masculine.
And so they feel that
masculinity and itself is toxic,
which is that's,
that's what I was going to ask you next
because the first video that really
hooked me,
it spoke to me personally,
both as a new father at the
time and perhaps also as a,
as a song of a deceased father.
Uh,
it was where you were talking about the
relationship one has with his father.
Um,
can you please elaborate
a little bit on that?
Well,
the proper role of a father
and a mother as well,
although the roles aren't identical.
I would say the,
the proper fundamental maternal
role is one of protection.
And the reason for that is quite obvious
is that newborn infants need above all
to be protected.
The proper response to
an infant's distress is,
you're right and I'll take
care of you right now,
especially for the first
nine months of life.
There's no disputing that
whenever the infant is upset,
he or she needs to be dealt with
as if that upset is justified.
But then as the infant matures,
and even by the age of nine months,
I would say then that that has to be,
that,
that that interaction has to be made more
sophisticated because the child has to
be encouraged to take his
or her place in the world.
And I would say that encouragement
is more on the masculine side of the,
of the,
of the duty distribution.
And their father's fundamental role is
to produce a bounded environment in which
exploration can take place with an eye
towards the encouragement of the child to
develop more and more competence
to push that development.
Because,
and it's true for mothers and fathers
that the end goal is to produce a person
who's capable of operating
autonomously in the world.
Now father's role is to foster that
sense of confident autonomy by by
encouraging the child to push his or her
limits and like that role can be played
by mother or father if
it's a masculine role.
It doesn't have to be played by a man,
but it's,
it's still tilts in that direction.
And so for example,
fathers are much more likely to engage
in rough and tumble play with their kids,
which is very,
very good for them by the way,
and absolutely necessary and
something to be completely encouraged.
Rough and tumble play at is
just fooling around wrestling,
wrestling,
physical play because the kids learn
while they learn all sorts of things.
It's like they learned to dance.
That's the best way of thinking about
it because a confident child understands
the physics of play and you can see
this even in said simple things is going
into a park where there's a lot of dogs
and the dogs that are well socialized
are very good at acting out playfulness
and you can tell the difference between
a growling dog and a mean dog and
afraid and dog and a playful dog.
People are very good at making that
distinction and a playful dog knows how to
move in a playful manner
and so does a playful child.
And that attentive readiness to play is
something that's fostered by those play
fight interactions with
fathers for example.
And that makes the kid ready in a deep
sense to engage with other children.
And it also sets the stage for a,
for a confident physicality and out in,
in adolescents and in
sexual relationships.
I mean,
and,
and so,
yeah,
because a lot of our wisdom
is embodied when you,
when you wrestle with kids,
then they learn what hurts
them and what doesn't.
They learn how far they can be
extended and stretched the limits.
He tests the limits they learned to trust
because you throw kids up in the air
and you catch them and you push them to
the point where they're really excited.
So they're right on the edge of fear.
Actually.
The excitement pushes right to the edge
of fear and but they learn and then they
also learn how they can interact with
someone else physically and what's
acceptable and where
the limits of pain are.
And what's frightening and what can be
sustained and how to take turns and all
of that.
And that's,
it's not abstract,
it's concrete.
It's right in the body.
And so,
so that's part of the father's role.
But the fundamental paternal
role is that of encouragement.
And the encouragement is you
can handle it kid life is hard.
It's going to come at you
and all sorts of ways.
You can accept that as a challenge.
You can thrive,
you can master it and I'm behind you.
Like I'm behind the best in you
manifesting itself in the world.
And that gives a kid a spine,
you know,
metaphysically and physic.
And so it's an unbelievably
important thing to do.
And fatherlessness is a catastrophe.
If you look at the
epidemiological literature,
the psychological literature,
fatherlessness predicts all
sorts of terrible outcomes.
It's not good.
And we've fallen into this idea in our
society that fathers aren't necessary.
It's like,
and it's just a family that's run by
single mother is just as good in in the
broad sense as a family with two parents.
And it's simply not true.
All the evidence suggests.
Now,
that doesn't mean that there aren't
single parents who were notably raising
their children because there are,
but in the aggregate,
the two parent family is a much
better arrangement for children.
She said that,
uh,
without the encoder Smith off the father,
is this as if it's spirit will be left
outside the walls of civilization?
Yes,
that's exactly,
that's exactly it is that,
you know,
the father's role is to,
to,
to note that the individual is capable
of thriving in a difficult world and to
put that message forward and to,
and to note that that's been the
message of people who've been successful
throughout history and that each
individual is capable of doing that,
at least to some degree
and has no better bet.
That's the,
as no better alternative.